What this does over here is this
gives us a visual representation
of that decision tree and
we can see how the model was created and
where it decided to splits in how many
records fell within each yeses and
noes at each split.
So the first split occurred
based off the spend.
Was it greater than or less than $9,549?
Based off of that decision,
it will go either to a yes bucket or
this further split.
So if it was greater than,
most likely they're going to be yes.
What you can see is 6% of the total
records are greater than that value, and
of that 6%,
88% of those of 78 records all together,
fell within the yes bucket.
So therefore, we're pretty sure that
if they're greater than this value,
they're going to be yes responders.
But if they're less than that,
where do they go?
They go to the stays per year split.
And there are some records
that fall within here.
But it's not enough to determine, hey,
do we need to make further splits or
not.
So, we could just keep on going down the
list to see where splits occurred and
the different number of records that
fell within that those different splits.
Base off in this model,
what was the confusion matrix?
So what this is going to show
me is that root mean error.
A root node error which tells me of our
total data set which is
the estimation sample.
How many of them fell within
the correct terminal node or not.
As you can see,
92% were actually classified correctly.
97% of the nodes were classified
correctly, while only 68% of
the yeses were classified correctly.
We had 32% of the yeses were actually
incorrectly classified as no and
vice versa where 3% of the noes
are incorrectly classified as yeses.
So this confusion matrix definitely
helps us determine where there might be
biases within our data, or if it's
maybe skewed to one side or the other.
So we can see that this model seems to
be pretty strong since it possesses
an accuracy of 92%.
Now let's actually run this model
against a real validation sample.
But first, take a look at
the following Decision Tree
interactive browse results, and
try answering a few questions about it.